في عام 1830 ، كتب الكاتب Honore de Balzac أن
كل من لا يزور باريس
بانتظام لن يكون أنيقًا أبدًا ،
والحمد لله أن باريس مرادف
للتسوق لأنها تمثل الأناقة
والآثار الشاسعة في المدينة للتسوق في
متاجرها هي وجهات في حد
ذاتها لا تقل جاذبية عن
برج إيفل  أم لا ، فأنت
الأقدم وربما الأكثر شهرة من بين كل
هذه الأشياء التي تقودها bon marché أو باللغة
الإنجليزية ، والصفقة الجيدة عادةً kubinashi L بالنسبة لي
، أذهب إلى المنزل ، وأعتقد أن القمر
الحريري الكلاسيكي أعود إلى المنزل ، وأعتقد أني مائدة جدًا
أكثر  ألبوم قائمة أنشطة الكحول في
الواقع نسافر على استخدام
مبارزة السماء الثانية ببساطة للإقلاع عن التدخين ، لا
تربط جيم أجاثا ليبوما بأوامر
تأتي في التخاطر مع التفاصيل التي
نحن أطول من 7/8 في المتوسط allahu ta âlâ
steed وزوجته مارغريت اك
سبت ببطء  العديد من المباني الأخرى حول
متجرهم لتشكيل متجر ضخم واحد
مؤطر بهذه الشوارع الأربعة ويقع في
باريس في الضفة اليسرى وهو
مرتبط حقًا بكل ما  ts
والأدب يشبه عالم الموضة
والجمال ومستحضرات التجميل تمامًا
[موسيقى]
دعنا نتخيل ناديك تذهب منجل إلى
حفلة شاي ، لقد طعنت زميلًا ،
نعم نفس الشيء إذا قام L الذي ابتكر هذا
الاقتراح بضرب ثوب أزرق في
حذاء مجلة  خزانة - تقصد
المعالج اللعنة ، حسنًا ، لقد كانت
حفلة هوكي مع أحدها جيدًا
أغاني التواصل الجيد الخاصة الغبية ، إشارة agua ،
مجلة t3 ، قم بوضعك ،
سمحت هذه البنية المعدنية
بإنشاء الستائر الزجاجية الضخمة للسماح بدخول
الكثير من الضوء الطبيعي إلى الخلف  في
منتصف القرن التاسع عشر ، كان هذا مهمًا بشكل خاص
لأن العديد من المباني استخدمت إضاءة الغاز
وتميل إلى أن تكون متضمنة تمامًا هناك
13 من هذه الحرم الجامعي وهي
سمة مميزة للمتجر ، لذا فإن
روح Beaumarchais هي حقًا هذا
الحمض النووي الباريسي الذي أعتقد أنه حقًا
شيء يمكن أن يكون لدى المتطفلين
هذه الرؤية أكثر من أنفسنا
لأننا نعيش هنا كما تعلمون على
عنقه سامانثا سأضيف هذا
الابتكار  التقشف ، مرحبًا ، كيف تفعل
السحر ، ردود الفعل الإلكترونية ، قيلولة صوتية
علمتني أنني أيضًا هل يمكن أن تكون كذلك ، كما
توقعت في المنزل ،
ينظم Le Bon marché أيضًا معارض منتظمة
مع الفنانين والمصممين
Martin Bar بطريقة طريقة جورجيو
الوطني العام الثاني مع الأطفال
وها نحن في مسيرة مهنية قصيرة رائعة Aminu chiana يتم تصنيع الكثير من المنتجات
في باريس ، لدينا الكثير من
العلامات التجارية المستقلة الصغيرة التي نحب أن يكون لدينا هذا
النوع من طباخ البودكاست ، إنه مثل ضربة
أو ضربة للقلب سحق أو
جاذبية قوية حتى الحب  للوهلة الأولى ،
وإذا كان لدينا هذا الطباخ ،
نأمل أن يحصل عليه عملاؤنا
معك